Les troupes aéroportées américaines ont
perdu plus de la moitié de leur matériel,
et 1 soldat sur 5.
Maintenant, ce sont ceux de la 81ᵉ
qui rejoignent la terre,
avant que leur camarade
ne leur rendent un dernier hommage.
- Prêt, en joue, feu.
En joue, feu.
Le 9 juin, les Américains s'emparent
de la petite ville d'Isigny.
Elle aussi rageusement bombardée pour
en déloger définitivement les Allemands.
Ce verrou empêchait les forces
d'Omaha et d'Utah de se rejoindre
pour se lancer ensuite sur Cherbourg.
Isigny prise,
le front allié, désormais réunie,
s'étend sur 100 kilomètres,
de Ouistreham, à la base
de la péninsule du Cotentin.
Si les hommes n'ont pas
eu besoin de port pour débarquer,
ils ont besoin maintenant de leur port
artificiel pour continuer la bataille.
Il faut bien que la logistique soutienne
les centaines de milliers de soldats alliés.
Chaque jour, 250 à 200 bâtiments,
déversent quelque 7000 véhicules.
15 000 tonnes de ravitaillement
et des milliers d'hommes
dans le port de Arromanches côté anglais,
et dans celui d'Omaha à côté américain.
Mais bientôt le temps se gâte et risque
encore une fois de tout compromettre.
Jamais depuis 40 ans,
une telle tourmente en Normandie,
avec à l'intérieur des aires de mouillage,
des bateaux devenus des chiens fous.
Le rempart des caissons s'avère
incapable de résister au cataclysme,
certains dérivent,
laissant s'engouffrer les flots.
Quai de déchargement
et passerelle flottante,
se désintègrent, balayés
comme des fétus de paille.
La tempête va durer 4 longs jours
qui interrompent l'approvisionnement,
et le renfort des troupes.
Le matin du 23 juin dévoile
le triste spectacle des navires
et des épaves qui, par centaines,
jonchent les plages.
Si les ingénieurs anglais
réparent vite Arromanches,
le port des Américains Omaha,
demeure hors d'usage.